the Joe Rogan experience so you started
out as a performance artist like that
was your idea what did you want to do
that was your idea your big idea I went
to art school for painting and I was got
really frustrated when people started to
critique the paintings and I was
supposed to be you know that getting
more serious in art school and more
conceptual and everyone was doing
something different and everyone was
critiquing it in a different way and
none of it made sense to me and then the
idea of having to sell that object that
you made so you're gonna make something
that's useless I mean that makes it
sound like I don't like or appreciate
art I just for me I didn't I couldn't
grasp what the next thing to do was you
know you're poor you're an art school
you're making something and then you
have to go sell and market that thing
and I also was frustrated and I kind of
like boiling inside and needed to
express myself so I started doing
performance art in school and I was like
when you say performance art that's a
pretty open-ended description oh it's so
open-ended there were so many like weird
performance art things that would happen
we I mean we had performance art class
there was a guy that like taped his
genitals to the side and put on lipstick
in a mirror and that was his performance
art piece or the girl that way and we
would all sit there and watch it
genitals did he go naked and pull it
aside or how did he do that that's a
really good question I like how your
mind just went there you're like what
actually happened I think I blocked it
out because I think you could probably
get away with doing that or the guise of
it being something you're doing you know
in a class someone yes yeah yes you get
away with that so pervy I think I was
focused on his beautiful lips I was
trying to be polite and I look down
there another woman was obese and her
piece was she had pre-setup we weren't
where she was doing the performance
butter Pat's in like dominoes like a you
know a few thousand of them you know
and she was obese and she crawled on the
ground she didn't actually eat them but
it was something that's weird my mind
kind of drops off I remember specific
parts of it but I don't remind the
butter pieces and crawling and away that
was her performance he's another guy the
this was I went to Detroit and then
finished in San Francisco and San
Francisco is known for being a real
performance art history a lot of the you
know the most famous performance artists
nobody knows where that was the scene
was in San Francisco so uh it was to
store a really beautiful campus
overlooking you could see a Lombard
Street on one side you could see the
water on the other side and another
guy's piece was to jump from the
second-story to a tree was like that he
may or may not have made the jump and
that was his art piece his art pieces
jumping from a window to a tree yeah
what the [ __ ] I know this other guy the
room where we had our class he had a
bread machine this was back you know
bread machines were new technology had a
bread maker you know those machines you
can make I guess it just does the dough
right right maybe it bakes in it I think
it just needs the dough and then you
bake it I don't know if you bake it in
the machine right no you bake it in the
machine it's all coming back to me he
bakes it in the machine we come into the
classroom as he's baking it there's
always like a reveal on these pieces
right so we come in he's taken plaster
from the wall and put it in the bread
he's fed us the bread half of us get it
half of us don't and there's plaster in
the bread why do you put plaster in his
bread it was something about I mean is
um get the bread some don't but even if
you get the bread there's plaster and so
in your face [ __ ] oh my god see there's
something about like performance are in
slam poetry those I did slam poetry -
that was my dude no I
here's the best part is I got zeros got
zeros yeah you didn't get any why I
never really wrote any poetry I was just
into the performance of it am I so you
didn't have a polling I was doing comedy
oh no which was very real for me but I
think I just wanted to express my I'll
said an ex-boyfriend who he said the
comedy was his life this was when I was
like 19 and I think I attached to people
like I thought he was the [ __ ] because
he would be rude to people like that was
his version of comedy was like bossing
people around or one of his bits was
like having a whistle and directing
traffic I mean really adolescent like
but for some reason I was really
attracted to him and like I wanted to be
him anybody who was like extroverted or
something that I wanted that's I was
attracted to that right so so he was
like comedy is my life and I do this
open mic and I was like I'm gonna do
that open mic and I had taped like
phrases to my body and phrases from
commercials or snippets of conversation
that I had heard and I went up and I
started reading them and then I would
improvise a little bit and I'd be like
waxy build-up or whatever I'm just
repeating just letting it all filter
through and come out my mouth for five
minutes of whatever the open mic was and
I started getting laughter but it was
like awkward laughter after the fact of
that uncomfortable like what it what is
she doing but my commitment level was so
high that the fact that it didn't make
any sense
just caused laughter right right right
right well that says that works
sometimes with just even with comics you
know absolutely there's a lot of people
that are just really odd and if you saw
them you would get it but if you saw
what they wrote on paper or what they
said just written down on paper you
would be like what that doesn't make any
sense yeah well I thought you were gonna
say which is a similar point that the
that it comes in the pause and after
what they're saying even if it doesn't
make any sense but you're saying
sometimes people write things and it
makes its own sense when you hear them
yeah I mean and but it's also just about
being full yes yes yes yeah and those
pauses yeah that gives you especially
something's really absurd gives you that
opportunity to go yeah you don't want to
just hammer them over the head with it
[Applause]